hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
early on in her work the ethics of
ambiguity simonda bouvoir
is going to use an expression which will
provide some
analysis and explanation to to will
oneself free and that is quite important
because
it's really at the center of the entire
project of the work it is you could say
the cornerstone
of the ethics that she's laying out and
i want to begin
by looking at one of the things she says
in the very beginning
part of that section and one of the
things she says at the very
end of that section before going into
the nitty-gritty
of her analysis and the analysis that
she's providing there
is a preliminary one it's going to get
more
uh you could say attention and and
you know additional explanations and
parts to it
throughout the rest of the work but but
what she's providing there is
enough to to go on so the first thing
that she says
this is at the very beginning of that
section
she tells us that by turning toward
this freedom this freedom of human
beings
we are going to discover a principle of
action
whose range will be universal
she goes on to say the characteristic
feature of all ethics is to consider
human life as a game that can be won or
lost
and to teach the human being the means
of winning so she
is in effect saying i'm doing what other
ethics have done i am providing you with
the
universal principle now it's going to be
kind of a strange
universal principle when we get to and
this is why
looking at the culmination of this
section
could in fact be quite useful so she
tells us
for the time being it is enough for us
to have established the fact that the
words to will oneself free
have a positive and concrete meaning
if the human being wishes to save their
existence as only they
themselves can do their original
spontaneity must be raised to the height
of moral freedom
by taking itself as an end through the
disclosure
of a particular content now that may
sound
rather abstract and in some some respect
it is
this what is this original spontaneity
well this
this goes to the analyses that she is
providing that john paul sartre her
partner
and collaborator is also providing in
other works about the human being
as being and what you know we can call
an original
flow of being into the world
and heidegger calls this in some respect
throneness
right we we are what we are we exist
assart expressed this by saying
existence precedes
essence and so she is working with this
this same idea herself she
she thinks that this is actually quite
correct this original spontaneity is
freedom but it's not freedom in you
could say its full
sense and so she says that
if we want to save our existence we have
to do something with this original
spontaneity
we have to take that freedom
as an end through disclosure of a
particular content what does this
disclosure
mean well we probably need to talk about
that as well
so from the perspective that that
sart and the bevoir and we can also say
heidegger in here it's essentially a
phenomenological perspective
although you know it doesn't have to be
just coming from phenomenology you can
also get this from german idealism and
from other sources
we as the human subject disclose the
being
of the world as a matter of fact this is
already there in
aristotle in rhetoric book two when he
tells us that due to the emotions
that you know we're seeing things you
could call this disclosing the
world we're seeing things differently
when we're angry than when we're calm
when we're afraid as when we're
confident so there's
a number of different ways in which we
disclose the being of the world
and we're not the only ones doing it
other people are doing it as well
and we can contest those disclosures
there's a lot more to be said there
the point is that we're never just an
isolated subject and then only coming to
the world
we're always caught up within the world
that we have a constitutive role in
disclosing
we can decide how we're going to look at
another word talking about this would be
framing
so early on in this discussion
she tells us that willing
involves a disclosure
of being right and so willing
is choosing it's making use of something
within ourselves
to decide things and she she tells us
here we go to wish for the disclosure of
the world
and to assert oneself as freedom are one
and the same movement she tells us we
will ourselves to be a disclosure of
being
and you you know you don't have to
necessarily say well you know
none of us actually like sit down and
think should i disclose being
option one should i not disclose being
option two
no we are we are already committed but
that doesn't mean that there isn't a
volition or willing there it's part of
how we are so she says we will ourselves
to be a disclosure of being if we
coincide with this wish we
we win the fact is the world becomes
present
by our presence in it but there's also
a perpetual tension to keep being at a
certain distance to not get lost in the
world to be
who we are as well we assert ourselves
as a certain kind of freedom over
against the world
and you can say well the way in which
you do that is just by acting as a
natural being in the world
you know your stimulus response and you
don't choose anything you're just
responding to things
that's not our common experience because
well you're you have this illusion of
free will
you know there's a lot of assumptions
packed into those
those claims that people make and what
is our experience our experience is that
we do choose within
environments we don't choose absolutely
in the sense of like
deciding to be in a totally different
environment or to be totally different
than we are but we do make we do
make some sort of choices or volitions
and she goes on and she says that
freedom
uh can be taken as an absolute end
that's what is at the core of her ethics
she said
the person who seeks to justify their
life must want
freedom itself absolutely they must will
freedom
itself absolutely and above everything
else so freedom becomes the top
value in it whatever hierarchy of values
or rank ordering
we have and freedom is a little bit
different though than than other
things you know if you say well maybe i
should put success or happiness or
something like that
as the top value or fulfilling my moral
obligations sure you always have to
specify what those mean
what does happiness actually look like
for you what does success look like for
you
it's probably very different for you
than it is for me
right or what would fulfilling moral
obligations be even if we have a very
uh formalist universalist
ethics that we still have to
particularize don't we
and freedom has to be realized as well
but freedom is not realized in these
concrete situations and choices
or in particular projects precisely the
same way that the notion of happiness or
eudaimonia
or success would be
because freedom always you could say
involves
itself that we we are free
to decide what freedom itself means and
we have to do that
so she talks about it as not being a
ready-made value which offers itself
from the outside to my abstract
adherence isn't that a nice way to frame
it
freedom is something that we can talk
about as
a value that you know some libertarian
you know writes a book and
you should be free in this respect
that's not full freedom
not from a de bevarian perspective
freedom
exceeds our conceptions of freedom
by being freedom so she says
that uh it appears not on the the plane
of facility but on the moral plane
as a cause of itself now that requires
just a little bit of explanation
does that mean that it's you know
producing
itself you could say almost like well i
mean
even classical theism don't say that god
produces
whatever god is just that god is an
uncaused cause
freedom is different than that freedom
does produce itself you you always have
a certain amount of freedom
you use that freedom to create more
freedom freedom
intrudes in ways that people often don't
want to admit because they
then they have to take responsibility
for what use they made of that freedom
so
freedom is a cause of itself but it's a
cause of itself through the human being
because it is the the freedom of the
human being it's not an abstract
freedom out there in the universe that
is causing itself and then you know
applies to us
it is in what we do that we we produce
we realize freedom
so then she raises a problem and this is
a significant one and a lot of what
what is happening in this this section
is
considering possible objections and then
clarifying in relation to them so she
says
that um sartre declares every person is
free there's no way of not being free
does this presence of a so to speak
natural freedom
contradict the notion of ethical freedom
what meaning
can there be in the words to will
oneself free
since at the beginning we are free right
if you want to will yourself to be
something
doesn't that imply that you have to like
change things
so you know if you want to will yourself
to be healthy
you don't do that as a healthy person
you do that as a sick person
well actually i mean this goes all the
way back to the plato symposium
where we're talking about desire this is
a certain kind of willing right
and uh you know we there's this notion
where you desire what you lack
and then deodoma points out no you could
actually have something and you desire
it
you desire to keep having it so you
could in fact desire to keep having
freedom you could will freedom in that
sense and then she says
something different simone bouvoir she
says
this objection would mean something only
a freedom were a
thing or a quality naturally attached to
a thing
if it was if it was something that has a
form once and for all
and we could like you know scoop out
maybe two units of freedom
and add them to the drink that then we
consume and now now we're free or
something like that
freedom doesn't work like that she says
if that was the case one would either
have it or not have it but the fact
is it merges with the very movement of
this
ambiguous reality which is called
existence and which
is only by making itself to be to such
an extent
it is precisely only by having to be
conquered that it gives itself
so what does this mean she she gives us
something in a sort of
uh you could say hegelian or german
idealist form
to will oneself free is to affect the
transition from nature to morality
by establishing a genuine freedom on the
original upsurge
of our existence so what is she talking
about with this nature morality thing
well
one way of understanding the human being
is that we are a natural being
and insofar as we're a natural being we
are governed by
essentially mechanical laws which which
you know make our bodies do what they do
and even psychological laws that pertain
to our our choices our desires our
inclinations our willings
this is straight out kant right but then
we also have this possibility of going
beyond that of escaping it and in kanye
we do that by
doing things that are you know represent
us as universals
and also you know stem from the uh
being that we are the numeral being the
thing
in itself the zaka's alps that that acts
and so
you know that's one way to look at it i
don't think you actually have to be
committed to that in order to make
sense of this but that does help you
understand what what she's getting at
she talks there about this original up
surge and then doing something on top of
that
so how do we how do we do that she says
we have to
assume our project positively
we have to set ends for ourselves
right she also talks about this
spontaneity
she says in its facticity every person
is originally free
in that they spontaneously cast
themselves in the world
if we she says consider this spontaneity
in its factity in how it appears to us
in what we can say about it
it appears only as a pure contingency
so i mean it's purely contingent that i
happen to be
at this point in time 50 years old six
foot three
you know that my hair grown on my face
is is a white mostly
and that on my head is still mostly
brown
and then i'm wearing this tie today any
of those things are purely contingent
they are the result of my
having chosen some of them some of them
i didn't choose at all i don't choose to
be 50 years old that's just the way
it is and so we can look at that we can
say well this is all just
absurd contingency none of it means
anything
really when we get down to it and she
brings up the
cleanup men or the swerve of the
epicurean atom
and says that this is like that so the
epicureans
a little bit of background knowledge in
order to preserve freedom
in an otherwise mechanistic universe
because they were committed to atomism
and saying that everything comes from
atoms and the ways in which they
interact with each other
they would say well every once in a
while for no reason whatsoever and adam
swerves
it just goes out of its normal course so
there's some randomness to it
and this gives us freedom freedom of of
ultimately the the will or the mind
and even back in ancient times people
like cicero were looking at that and
they're like
this does not solve the problem at all
this just introduces randomness
but it doesn't introduce any meaning or
intelligence or anything like that
that's not what we're talking about
and so we have to go beyond this mere
spontaneity she says
in order for this meaning to justify the
transcendence
which discloses it it must be founded
which it will never do if i do not
choose to found it myself and she says
we can evade that choice
we can choose not to will ourselves free
we can
be lazy heedless capricious cowardly
impatience we can test the meaning of
the project at the very moment we
define it but if we want to be free we
have to assume
our projects positively
and we have to set ends we have to
choose those ends she says it's through
this
end that it sets itself up that my
spontaneity confirms itself by
reflecting upon itself it's no longer
pure spontaneity by
reflecting upon itself right and then
she says
by a single movement my will
establishing the content of the act is
legitimated by it
so this is a an important
aspect there's also an important
temporal
discussion there as well where again she
refers to the epicurean clinimen but we
could refer to so many other things
including the cliche of oh man you
should just live for the moment just be
in the moment and she would say that's
not real freedom
that's not the way to free yourself the
existentialists
think that a human being does have to
have a past does have to have a future
not just a present so she she says that
you can
escape the absurdity of the clinton men
only
by escaping the absurdity of the pure
moment and existence would be unable to
found itself
if moment by moment it crumbled into
nothingness
and you know so she goes on she says
that's why no moral question presents
itself to a child as long as they are
incapable of
recognizing that is taking stock of
themselves reflexively
in the past or seeing themselves in the
future it's only
when moments of one's life begin to be
organized into behavior
comportment that one can decide
and choose otherwise it's just sort of
flailing around just doing things right
not not a really human
use of freedom so we have to escape the
absurdity of this pure moment
and here she talks about persevering
in willing now this is very interesting
as well because this this idea
actually has a history that i think de
bevar herself
is not entirely aware of in
anselm's works he actually deliberately
coins it's in the de libertate uh he
coins a new term perevele
and he says that this is to will
what one wills repeatedly to persevere
persevare in willing something and
choosing something so persevering
in willing is important she says to will
is to engage myself to persevere
in my will she also
brings up something very interesting
here because she talks about
some comportments that we would call
virtues
that one has to choose to display
patience courage fidelity
faithfulness and that would be ways in
which we
determinately but also in a general way
persevere and willing
we have the thing that we are willing
and then we do so
courageously patiently faithfully
so it's not just pure whim and we can't
just abandon
everything at any moment for this
existentialist at least
she says that um i must ceaselessly
return
to what i've willed and justify it in
the unity of the project with which i
am engaged setting up the movement of my
transcendence requires i never let it
uselessly fall back on itself that i
prolong it
indefinitely and so
this is carried out through human action
we also encounter resistance
and we encounter failures
where we ourselves are not able to will
successfully
what it is that we want to will we were
unable to
to attain the ends that we've set for
ourselves and so she says
we don't create the world we succeed in
disclosing it only through the
resistance what the world
opposes to us the will is defined only
by raising obstacles
and the contingency of tacticity certain
obstacles let themselves be conquered
others do not we you know again to be an
existentialist and think that we
well we have free will and we have to
will ourselves free doesn't mean you can
automatically do anything
it doesn't mean that everything will go
as you're you're willing it
and she talks about different responses
to this so one is to to
fall into an abstract notion of freedom
that is saved in certain types of
comportments
she says in the face of an obstacle
which is impossible to overcome
stubbornness which is one of those is
stupid
if i persist in beating my fist against
a stone wall my freedom exhausts itself
in this useless gesture it debases
itself in a vain
contingency she also talks about
disillusioned indifference
and resignation as ways in which people
could do this as well and she says the
power of the human being ceases to be
limited because it's a nulled
she also then suggests that we could
take an end
that has set ourselves an end in
engaging in projects which is nothing
but the free movement
of existence and she gives us an example
here vincent van gaal
where uh when he's no longer able to do
the creative work
which is what he centers his life around
that you know he's got
talent that's part of his fact history
he chooses
to engage in in painting as a practice
as a way of living
as something that he perseveres in
and then it becomes impossible for him
he's confined to an asylum does this
mean that
his life as a free person is over
so she says when the sick van gogh
calmly accepted the prospect of a future
in which he would be unable to paint
anymore
there was no sterile resignation for him
painting was a personal way of life and
of communication with others
which in another form could be continued
even in
an asylum and now here she brings back
the temporal aspect
she tells us the past will be integrated
freedom will be confirmed in a
renunciation of this
kind it will be lived in both heartbreak
and in joy affectivity plays a role
there so temporality affectivity
she also talks about the possibility of
revolt and
some revolt she says could be a pure
negative moment if that's the case it
remains abstract
it is fulfilled as freedom only by
returning to the positive
giving itself as again she says a
content
through action escape political
political struggle revolution
she acknowledges that there will be
cases where this is not possible
that um there are situations where the
return to the positive
cannot happen because the future is
radically blocked
off revolt can then be achieved only in
the definitive
rejection of the imposed situation and
suicide right
but she thinks that that we can in fact
in most cases
save our freedom by using our freedom
and she closes in this by bringing up a
really
key idea which we'll see her develop
elsewhere in this work
by saying that
just as life is identified with the will
to live freedom always appears as a
movement of liberation
it is only by prolonging itself through
the freedom of
others that it manages to surpass death
itself and to realize itself as an
indefinite unity
so if we want to save our existence
then we must also work for the freedom
of others as well the meaning of our our
freedom lies
in part in the freedom of others which
is not something we can master
and makes a lot of people anxious if
that's the case
so this is a robust
analysis of what it means to will
ourselves free it's going to attain more
and more discussion
as the work proceeds but this is sort of
the
the core and the crux of it
you